the five most amazing moves of Wang Hao
from China in this video we're gonna
look at five brilliant moves that Wang
Hao has played the Chinese tiger is
playing in two candidates and could be
well championed this time next year see
if you can find the magical moves he
played good luck and let me know in the
comments how you get on this first very
exciting example just demonstrates what
you need to do when both sides have
castled and opposite sides of the board
it's all about attack attack attack he
who strikes first
normally crashes through black plays
rook to b7 and now violence is required
break down the black king can you see
how Bishop takes g6 and this is a
brilliant way to get through to the
black King even if it costs points we
need to just attack keep throwing
everything get the kitchen sink get
anything put them towards the black King
the point of this idea is if F takes G 6
our Queen takes one step nearer we have
a devastating idea of rook h7 here and
if something like Bishop f7 there is a
very nice tactical blow here can you see
the blow this is one situation where I'm
not going to show you but let's see who
gets it in the comments first below
black didn't like this and after Bishop
takes g6 decided to attack instead with
b4 timing is everything in such a
position we don't want to defend we want
to keep coming forwards retreat defense
is for wimps not the Chinese tiger so he
continues with another blow rook to h7 a
fourth piece dives in and the pressure
around the black King is just becoming
too much if this rook is taken then
White has a number of strong moves
Bishop takes h7 been the most simplest
way in this complex position to win and
the Queen dives in and after rook takes
h7 black tries pawn takes Knight when
he's won
move away from winning with devastating
ideas but it is white to move so you've
got to play aggressively what's the best
move Bishop takes f7 check and this
forces away through so the rook has to
be taken and now just rook to h1 and
black resigns beautiful tactics blow
after blow dare to take the black King
and down in the second example wang hao
is faced with imminent danger Queen to
e7 checkmate so again it's important to
play with some urgency what did the
Chinese Tiger now do to force check mate
may be a bit of an easier one this one
you have to play the regression and it's
all about getting your most important
pieces into the attack your Queen rook
to h1 check and this allows the Queen to
swing into action here the rook has to
be taken the Queen comes over with check
and around here white resigned because
it's easy to see with a series of checks
there is no escape Queen hg2
would lead to checkmate so I'll put up
free they say that the following move
that's played in this game is one of the
hardest moves to spot maybe a bit of a
clue there white has a lot of pressure
against the black King all the whites
pieces look quite actively placed but
there's one move here that's just the
knock out blow can you see that blow
Knight to f4 the reason I said this is a
very hard move to spot is because it's a
backwards Knight move and notoriously
backwards Knight moves are not in a lot
of humans vision of sights and vision of
sights as what we need when was spotting
tactics the idea behind this very clever
move is that Knight to g6 checkmate is
one fret so for example black actually
resigned here but if Queen takes pawn
Knight to g6 would win the Queen for not
very much and if the knight is captured
and as the lovely checkmate
Queen takes h7 and after King takes root
2 H 4
checkmate so maybe a very short tactic
but a very visually pleasing one this
next example actually has a name the
technique used by the Chinese Tiger Wang
Hao in this position with the black
pieces is named from an idea that
Blackburn actually played in one of his
games Blackburn a leading English player
many a moon ago with so many pieces
around the White King it's clear
something has to give but what move
breaks through White's protection here
can you see it look for aggressive moves
again you're trying to get to that king
queen takes h4 very forcing move it may
look like this is a blunder because I'll
know why can white can take my queen but
this now opens the way for the bishop on
e5 and Bishop to h2 is check mate
so in actual fact after Queen takes h4
there's nothing to be done because black
is threatening a checkmate on not one
square but two squares so white has to
resign this last example looks curtains
for black it's black to move but white
is threatening simply Knight g5 and
Queen h7 checkmate in VO where the white
pieces must have been thinking yeah your
time's up Chinese tiger I am the Dragon
Slayer or even a tiger Slayer you know I
sure don't like Tiger Slayers not cool
but the black wang hao had a brilliant
idea prepared in this position it looks
impossible that he can survive with so
many pieces on the wrong side of the
board but he pulls out a Harry Houdini
if you can't win and you're about to
lose obviously a draws okay that's a
little clue and he now plays Knight to
d3 what is this magic well the point
that this is if rook takes Queen well
you've lost a queen but you can now go
Knight to f4 check and actually gain a
perpetual
check is simply it's simply astonishing
and we can see this perpetual check
after King to g3 and now nighty to and
there's nothing that the white king can
do here if the White King tries to
escape to the back rank we do have a
very useful rook and that rook can come
flying in with deadly effect so a very
nice way to escape the troubles are the
moves after Knight D free also don't
work for example Knight to g5 straight
away fails tonight to wear for check and
then after something like King G free
black is the one attacking and will
actually checkmate with Bishop d2 and
another very nice idea is if rook takes
Knight Black has an amazing move here
and again I'm gonna leave this for you
guys to solve remember Queen takes rook
Knight g5 could be quite problematic so
you need to find what is called an
intermezzo move first
beautiful defensive play dead Oh from
Wang Hao thank you for watching the five
most amazing moves of wang hao who is a
brilliant player from china and again
another guy i would not like to face at
the board who's capable of winning the
candidates which of those moves did you
like the best and did you see them all i
have to say some of my struggle with
this time so please like and subscribe
to this video and i hope to see you all
again soon